well the guy can hold the audience I'll
give him that latest episode of Gotham
That's Entertainment
I'm gonna be getting into spoilers
almost immediately so yeah I'm not even
sure you can really talk about my
thoughts in this one without getting
into spoilers so here we go
this thing has almost everything that I
love about Gotham it's got just a high
level of what I would just call bonkers
miss it's got flamboyant characters it's
got insane stakes it's got crazy plot
turns it's got just the right amount of
nods to what the future of characters
like Bruce will ultimately end up being
so why don't I actually like this
episode all that much I think it's a
combination of two things the first
being it's pretty predictable really
because I mean I want to say we've seen
this multiple times before I'm not
actually sure we've seen it multiple
times but certainly in terms of the
there's a gas that's about to be spread
across the town we saw that last year
with with Mad Hatter's whole formula
that he made based off Alice's blood and
what we see here with the attempt of
Jerome and his and his crew to gas a
chunk of Gotham it's not bad it's not a
bad spin on it but it is very very very
close to being the same thing and that
one was more jacked up because you know
you had Lee involved doing it and she
had already lost her mind where is this
it's the crazies acting crazy it's
pretty much what we expect out of it so
it feels like the whole scenario feels
like a retread that's the first problem
and then the problem on top of that is
it didn't surprise me I mean Gotham
Gotham is at its best
when it takes insane plot turns that I
didn't see coming and it's not like it
necessarily does wrong poles or big
twists but just this show is that it's
best when it pushes things to a degree
or in a direction that I'm like okay no
other show would do that but okay and
that doesn't feel like the case here
this whole plot feels much more generic
and for all the build-up it's just kind
of uh just kind of a letdown and you
know ultimately our resolution is what I
figured it was as soon as Jeremiah got
introduced which is you know Jerome's
dead and you know now we've got now
we've got his brother who's actually
going to be the Joker oh the other thing
that feels really repetitive like
Jerome's whole thing on the stage you
know with his hostages is really
reminiscent of the season 2 episode
which was actually the first time he
died so not only have we kind of feel
like we've been repeating that same
scenario but he dies in both things
which makes it all the more repetitious
and I suppose an argument could be made
for a certain kind of narrative symmetry
to that you know echoes of repeating
things or whatever but it doesn't feel
like that it feels like it just feels
like it happens to be hitting on the
same notes again it's not addressing
that in a way that feels like it was
done with purpose or with meaning it
just kind of happens so that feels
repetitious the overall setup feels
repetitious I don't love what's going on
with Barbara actually Tabitha herself
had the line that I was saying in my
head she says to Barbara this is not the
bar where I know no kidding I love
Barbara Barbara is great because like
Gotham itself Barbara is nuts and
Barbara is nuts in a joyous chaotic way
and now she's weirdly obsessive with
this idea that she's like a reincarnated
Queen sort of general thing
and it's obviously all being thrown into
question because now we've got this
other group but I'm assuming Tabitha's
gonna try out to be the show's version
of Thalia or something along those lines
but it doesn't help but I've said this
before that although the Ra's al Ghul's
stuff has all been the least interesting
part of this season at all so having it
come back in the first place doesn't
thrill me and what it's doing to Barbra
as a character makes me annoyed that
they bring her back at this point I'm
going back to what I said early in the
season I would rather they had her die
in her showdown with Tabitha that that
when she got electrocuted that was it
she was dead because what they brought
her back for I'm just not feeling I I
think I think Ra's al Ghul was a bad fit
for Gotham and just to rehash quickly my
fundamental issue with Ra's al Ghul is
that this show is nuts but it's Mad
Science nuts Ra's al Ghul is mystical
nuts and four seasons in it this does
not feel like a proper fit this does
this this feels crowbarred in this isn't
working so you know maybe because like I
said there's obviously something weird
going on with this maybe by the end
it'll pan out into something I'm more
okay with right now not loving this I'm
realizing as I'm talking it out I'm just
I'm pretty down on this episode overall
I think I actually genuinely didn't
really like it I kept wanting to like it
kept wanting to be engaged by it it kept
doing things that I'm like I should be
liking this but it didn't because it
reminded me of times the show did the
same thing but better or it took
characters that I liked and did things
with them that I'm like that it's not
why I like this character so there were
a couple of good moments I liked the
moment between Bruce and Alfred Alfred
giving him the car obviously it's our
preliminary Batmobile a great moment
when
Gordon pulls up to you know the concert
that Jerome took over and then they're
playing they're playing the the 60s
Batman theme music that's seeing it that
that's great that was awesome
so like there's some good little moments
like that and but you know those are
just kind of sprinkled across and the
rest of it yes just it's retreads or or
it's stuff I'm not interested in and
it's annoying because I love this show
and the fact that so many of the
elements of this episode do feel like
the show did them at least once before
makes me very very worried about the
future of this show I mean I I don't
have inject today I don't think it's
officially gotten a renewal yet so
there's a possibility this is the last
season anyway but it's got it's got a
50/50 shot at renewal assuming that it
gets renewed for another season III if
it does I will actually be somewhat
nervous because I'm starting to get the
feeling they may they may be running low
on ideas of how to escalate things
anymore because the the you know the
show's turn things up past eleven more
than a few times and you know once you
do that you can't go bigger anymore and
then you just start repeating yourself
and I'm starting to worry that that's
the point that Gotham is hit which is
annoying to see so I think this is the
first like full episode I've been down
on in a long time actually maybe even
since the second season which is still
my favorite I'm not even sure they're
maybe since the first season because you
know I think of other stuff that I
haven't loved and it's been like one
element in an episode that I could find
you know a lot of stuff that still
worked for me this one stuff that works
are tiny moments they're they if the
thing was was flipped and like I mostly
liked it in the
that I do in fact like work is you know
say problems with it if I were to flip
that dynamic they would just be nitpicks
so putting it back to how it actually is
okay so they're positive but the
whatever the positive equivalent of a
nitpick is they don't matter there are
little things they come and they go and
they don't save it much like a nitpick
doesn't wreck something usually so yeah
I'm just I get the distinct feeling I'm
alone in this feeling Ivan I haven't
like done a dive into reviews but just
sort of quick snapshot reaction to this
thing people seem to really dig it and
really liked it so maybe I'm just a
party pooper I don't know but this
didn't work for me guys and it should
have it's got all the elements but
they're they're not fresh and then that
may be not like the episode and it makes
me worried so that'll be it
latest episode of Gotham tell me why I'm
wrong cuz like I said general consensus
seems to be a lot more positive than my
feelings on the thing so whatever your
thoughts are keep them respectful but by
all means tell me why I'm wrong and why
this is great drop something down in the
comments let's talk about there's all
the stuff to do like support me on
patreon listen to podcast follow me on
Twitter links for all that stuff down in
the description until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]